Bonjour à toutes et à tous, vous avez vu, en France,en été, il fait de plus en plus chaud.
Franchement ça va ! Faut toujours que t'exagères !
Concrètement, ça implique que vous transpirez beaucoup trop, et que vos
camarades de métro sentent un petit peu mauvais, mais en plus ça a 2/3 conséquences sur notre
environnement. Les lacs s'assèchent, les vignesaussi, les poissons meurent et les moustiques
nous emmerdent. Mais aujourd'hui on va vous parlerdes arbres, parce que c'est important les arbres.
Eh oui, c'est une vraie question ça : comment lesarbres de nos belles forêts vont-ils encaisser cette
aridification du climat ?
Pour le savoir, il va nousfalloir prendre de la hauteur : direction les Alpes
de Haute Provence, à 3 mètres 50 du sol, sur un siteexceptionnel : l'O3HP. Il a été développé au
sein d'une forêt naturelle de chêne pubescent, pour observer au plus près leur adaptation face
aux changements climatiques. Cet endroit permet d’ausculter la forêt de la tête aux pieds, mais aussi
de la faire voyager dans le temps, en voyantà quoi elle pourra ressembler dans le futur.
La base du dispositif, c'est une plate-forme longue
de dix mètres, qui a été installée à deux niveaux de
hauteurs différentes : à 3 mètres 50 et à 80 cm, pour
pouvoir observer à la fois la canopée mais aussi
les troncs des arbres. Ensuite, les scientifiques
ont mis en place une expérience pour comparer
trois parcelles : dans la première on a construit
un dispositif composé de volets hermétiques qui
permettent d'intercepter 30 à 40% de la pluie pour
simuler un climat aride sur cette parcelle de laforêt.
Les chercheurs peuvent les ouvrir et les
fermer à leur guise, en fonction de la météo. Bon,
là par exemple, on était à quelques minutes d'unénorme orage.
Mais c'est horrible ! Mais c'est pas du
tout détox comme régime, hein, c'est l'inverse qu'ilfaut faire ! Il faut leur donner du jus d'épinards
aux baies de goji, et des smoothies aux
brocolis et choux raves !
Ces arbres, artificiellement
confrontés à un changement climatique sévère sont
ensuite comparés à ceux d'une parcelle témoin :
l'essai face à notre climat actuel soumis à desprécipitations normales. Ils sont aussi comparés à
des arbres d'une parcelle irriguée, qui échappent
donc à la sécheresse estivale naturelle.
Mais alors, du coup, comment on compare ? Dans ce système
d'exclusion de pluies dynamique, des dizaines
de capteurs permettent de mesurer six paramètres
environnementaux, comme la température, l'humidité...
et ce, à différents niveaux du sol et de la
canopée. Le but : comprendre la corrélation entre ces
paramètres et l'évolution de la santé des arbres.
On s'occupe donc de prendre le pouls des chênes,
transformés en véritables rats de laboratoire, grâce
à des capteurs permettant de mesurer les flux de
sève. Plus l'arbre est vigoureux, plus la sève monte
vite, plus l'arbre grandira ; comme un ado, un peu.
La force de l'O3HP, c'est qu'on ne s'occupe pas
uniquement de l'arbre isolé, mais de l'arbre au
sein de son écosystème ; c'est-à-dire dans une forêt
naturelle, dans toute sa complexité, où cohabitent
de nombreuses espèces végétales et animales. Desanalyses précises sont donc également menées sur
le sol dans lequel les arbres sont plantés. Ducoup, les scientifiques dissèquent la forêt à tout
les niveaux : de la cime des arbres à leurs racines.
En s'intéressant aussi à l'aération des sols, grâce
à des cloches en verre. Eh oui, on dit souvent que
les forêts sont les poumons de notre planète,
sauf que pour que les arbres fassent leur boulot
et nous aident à respirer, il faut que la terre qui
les accueille respire, elle aussi. Et n'oublions
pas non plus qu'un arbre a besoin de se nourrir.
Pour cela, il faut que les matières organiques,
qu'il rejette sous forme de feuilles mortes,
soient recyclées en produisant de la biomasse, et donc
des nutriments ; vous savez le fameux phosphore et
le célèbre azote, dont nous avons parlé dans notre
vidéo sur les toilettes du futur :
"Tu recycles touuuut !"
Eh ben, les arbres aussi ils en ont besoin, et pour
ça ils doivent compter sur des petits animaux qui
vivent juste à leurs pieds et qu'on appelle lamésofaune. La mésofaune, c'est la faune qui a
une taille comprise entre 0,2 et 4 mm. Ça inclutdes animaux comme les acariens les collemboles et
autres arthropodes trop mignons. Enfin, trop mignons...Non, en vrai, ils sont laids comme des poux, mais
on va pas se mentir ils sont très utiles, en toutcas. Ils mangent les feuilles mortes et contrôlent
la prolifération des micro-organismes dans lessols. Ils sont ensuite consommés par des insectes
de plus grande taille, comme les araignées oules pseudo-scorpions, qui eux-mêmes nourriront
les oiseaux, etc. etc... Vous connaissez le principe, ça s'appelle la "chaîne alimentaire" et c'est nous
qui gagnons à la fin. Sauf contre la plupart desours. Les chercheurs leur portent donc une attention
toute particulière, et pour savoir comment ils sesentent en milieu aride, il faut retourner sur le
terrain. Voici des bacs permettant de récolter lalitière au pied des arbres, afin de quantifier la
production de biomasse, en fonction du contexteclimatique. Heureusement, à l'O3HP, on est
équipés pour mener une démarche scientifique de Aà Z. On peut donc passer directement du terrain au
laboratoire pour observer tout ça. Ici, on récupèretoutes les petites bébêtes présentes dans ce sol. On
les observe à la loupe binoculaire pour identifier
tout ce petit monde, et hop ! On peut dresser la
courbe de population de la mésofaune en fonctionde l'évolution du climat. Et là, le tableau est
pas jojo. En cas d'aridité,  les organismesdétritivores meurent plus facilement que leurs
prédateurs, et cette chute démographique importante
ralenti le processus de décomposition des sols, ce
qui impacte alors toute la biodiversité à grande échelle. Et là, vous allez me dire : "Cent
acariens de plus ou de moins, qu'est ce que ça peutvous faire ? Franchement, vous cherchez toujours la
petite bête vous les écolos, hein."
Ben, non parce que situ affaiblis un maillon de la chaîne, c'est toute
la faune qui se retrouve en danger. Un puceron quimeurt, c'est potentiellement une coccinelle affamée.
Or, ces petites bêtes-là sont essentielles àl'entretien d'une belle structuration du sol. On
dit même que les vers de terre sont les ingénieursdu sol, c'est dire ! Et un sol mal structuré, ça peut
causer des érosions des terres arables, donc unebaisse de la fertilité des champs, et même des
glissements de terrain qui fragiliseront nosconstructions. Alors, pour garder ta villa
en place et ton frigo bien plein, tu ferais biende protéger les petites bêtes. Bon soyons calmes
et posées : est-ce que c'est vraiment le début del'apocalypse ? Pour le moment, le chêne pubescent
résiste plutôt bien à la diminution simulée des précipitations, même s'il encaisse une
légère baisse de croissance. Il est résilient, lechêne. Enfin pour l'instant, car pour le moment
les scientifiques peuvent observer de légèrestendances, mais c'est dur de savoir s'il le sera
encore dans cinquante ans. Et ça, c'est le drame, parce que le chêne pubescent, c'est quand même
le papa de la truffe.
-Moi ?
-Mais non pas toi, le champignon. Enfin, la truffe qui se mange, quoi.
Et autant vivre dans un monde sans acariens, moi ça me va, autant vivre dans un monde sans
truffe : no way. Heureusement, les chercheurs del'O3HP tirent des conclusions précieuses de
leurs recherches, pour limiter l'impact négatif del'aridification. Grâce à leur savoir, ils peuvent
aider à la gestion forestière de demain, et onva en avoir besoin, parce que des campagnes de
plantation d'arbres sont actuellement mises enplace, pour atténuer les effets du changement
climatique. Et injecter de l'argent pour planterdes forêts, c'est bien, mais éviter de planter un
chêne peu résistant qui va crever dans troisans, c'est mieux pour pas passer pour un gland.
Nos experts donnent donc des pistes pour reforester la France avec des essences plus
appropriées, pour effectuer une transition touten douceur. Leur conseil : éviter de planter des
espèces mono-spécifiques. En effet, certains arbressont naturellement accompagnés de types de plantes
qui leur font du bien : c'est ce qu'on appelle lesespèces compagnes. La préservation de ces groupe
de potes chlorophyllés aide à la bonne santé dela forêt toute entière. La solution pour une France
qui respire à pleins poumons verts, c'est donc ladiversité forestière. Et après tout, si au final on
a moins de truffes et moins de glands, ça nous feraitde l'air !
Merci à tous d'avoir regardé cette vidéo,
on espère que ça vous aura plu et que ça vousaura donné envie de chouchouter nos forêts, qui
morflent un peu plus chaque été. Alors n'oubliez pas: ne jetez pas vos mégots, triez vos déchets, abonnez
vous à cette chaîne et lâchez-nous un pouce bleu.
Eh, abonnez-vous à cette chaîne. Le... Le chêne...